when you think about how people can buy
bitcoin and pay no taxes on that like
explain how that works according to the
current tax code so what the irs has
built this is back 30 40 years ago is
they built what's called a qualified
rapper think of it as like a brokerage
or a coinbase account that has this
wrapper around it that enables you to
not pay short-term capital gains so when
you trade on coinbase and your or any of
these other exchanges you have the
situation where you're paying
income tax basically if you're trading
within a year when you're in an ira or a
qualified rapper that doesn't exist you
can trade your heart away until you're
old fat and gray and you don't pay
capital gains on that until way way way
later and then you pay a total tax
on income once you take it out so the
irs has built this for us it's built for
hodlers it's amazing so it's not just
trading but hodling you can accumulate
and you don't see any taxes until you're
old and if it's a roth ira you don't see
any taxes ever and so we're seeing a
nucleus of our a cohort of users that
are putting dollars into bitcoin in a
roth ira and then when they are when
they graduates that 59 and a half age
they never have to pay taxes on that
again they're living in a bitcoin
circular economy at that point and
they're starting to think think about
that where bitcoin is the actual
currency that they're looking at using
so when i basically have post-tax
dollars and i use a roth ira i put those
post-tax dollars into my retirement
account i can buy bitcoin and regardless
if i think i'm a genius day trader or i
want to just hold at age 59 and a half i
can begin to take that stuff out and pay
no taxes exactly exactly also seek your
own tax advice but that's the way that
the written rules are work right now and
then in terms of if i don't use a roth
ira if i go ahead and i put dollars into
my retirement account i trade no tax no
taxes and then the only time i would
ever pay taxes in that scenario at 59
and a half when i go to take it out i
basically pay taxes at the very end
whatever the amount is that i'm taking
out bingo and by that point what we see
in the u.s retirement system and like
americans is that you're typically
working a little less your your like
salary will go down so your total income
tax will go down hopefully we'll see but
but that's the point is you're building
our users aren't like i don't think when
i think of choice we're third
so you typically don't buy bitcoin for
the first time in your ira you typically
go down the rabbit hole with gbtc or
coinbase or kraken or one of these
others you then go you then learn about
it and then you realize oh there's 30
100 000 bucks sitting in this thing over
here that i haven't looked at for years
we want to be second and third it's a
third stack right so if you're out there
stacking stats every day this is not
necessarily the primary way you got in
but now it's the completion of your
financial picture of where you got
bitcoin exposure in that qualified
capacity which is big
can people actually contribute bitcoin
into their retirement or do they
contribute dollars i'm working i'm
lobbying on that right now so right now
the way that the irs has written this is
that you got to do dollars but here's
the good news about that so to be clear
you have to go dollars into retirement
account you can't go bitcoin from your
coinbase or whatever account into your
time right but on a stock to flow model
that's really good because what we're
seeing is net fresh new dollars coming
in and buying bitcoin so that's it's
it's a positive thing especially for me
as a bitcoin that's trying to advance
the space i'm looking at every a month
we're getting between 30 to 100 million
dollars a month coming in from the
legacy retirement system in dollars and
it's going into bitcoin and to me that
gets me super excited because i know
that that's 20 30 40 year capital from
the average bitcoiner who's like 30
something years old had a few jobs et
cetera
that's quality are most people trading
inside of their retirement accounts are
they just buying assets and holding them
for a long period of time two cohorts
you know the guys and gals that are
holding your own keys they're not
trading they're they're here they're
here for the long run the ones that are
holding it fidelity digital they're long
long term people you do see
i i trade a little bit i've traded some
in the last few days i you do see some
cohort that are doing it because they
don't have to pay that short term uh
capital gains issue that they're getting
in all their crypto exchanges that's
good we i don't necessarily um
uh faults that but what again what our
mission is trying to do is i don't want
you day trading your wealth away right
even if even if you may have the ability
to do that and that's great not all of
our users do i want you building wealth
every day and that's a big reason why
we've actually you know if you think
about our second mission that's a big
reason for what we've done with
something called blinko
we've created this game that literally
gives you bitcoin if you play it every
day and puts a little bit in your pocket
towards that long-term savings so we
want people that are thinking about it
in the long term john you had a good
text this morning in light especially
what's going on most of our users that
are coming to the market and are coming
to us right now aren't thinking about
how do i
accumulate bitcoin so that i can be rich
in two to three years they're thinking
about how do i accumulate bitcoins to
diversify my long-term wealth over the
next 30 years that's the user we want
and that's that's who we're getting and
that's
and and that's the bitcoin really if you
think about it most of us as you know
anthony we're not here we're not here
for a quick like in and out this is a
long-term structural thing where i'm
building a better financial future for
my son for our kids not necessarily just
get in and out so that i can go to the
beach and and hang out more and for
joe's dog ranger yeah yeah johnny
rangers for sure yeah